just a quick note before we get started
to experience and practice one of the
most important themes from this episode
stick around after the interview for a
guided loving kindness meditation from
Jack he is very famous for these and for
a very good reason
this episode is brought to you by
element spelled lmnt what on Earth is
element it is a delicious sugar-free
electrolyte drink mix I've stocked up on
boxes and boxes of this was one of the
first things that I bought when I saw
covid coming down the pike and I usually
use one to two per day element is
formulated to help anyone with their
electrolyte needs and perfectly suited
to folks following a keto low carb or
paleo diet or if you drink a ton of
water and you might not have the right
balance that's often when I drink it or
if you're doing any type of endurance
exercise mountain biking Etc another
application if you've ever struggled to
feel good on keto low carb or paleo it's
most likely because even if you're
consciously consuming electrolytes
you're just not getting enough and it
relates to a bunch of stuff like a
hormone called aldosterone blah blah
blah when insulin is low but suffice to
say this is where element again spelled
lmnt can help my favorite flavor by far
is Citrus salt which is a side note you
can also use to make a cake S no sugar
Margarita but for special occasions
obviously you're probably already
familiar with one of the names behind it
Rob wolf Robb Rob Wolfe who is a former
research biochemist and two-time New
York Times best-selling author of The
Paleo Solution and wired to eat Rob
created element by scratching his own
itch that's how it got started his
Brazilian Jiu Jitsu coaches turned him
on to electrolytes as a performance
enhancer things clicked and Bam company
was born so if you're on a low carb diet
or fasting electrolytes play a key role
in relieving hunger cramps headaches
tiredness and dizziness sugar artificial
ingredients coloring all that's garbage
unneeded there's none of that in element
and a lot of names you might recognize
are already using element it was
recommend to be by one of my favorite
athlete friends three Navy SEAL Teams as
prescribed by their Master Chief Marine
units FBI sniper teams at least five NFL
teams who have subscriptions they are
the exclusive hydration partner to Team
USA weightlifting and on and on you can
try it risk-free if you don't like it
element will give you your money back no
questions asked they have extremely low
return rates for a limited time you can
get a free element sample pack with any
purchase it's the perfect way to try all
of their flavors or if you're feeling
generous sharing with a friend who might
enjoy this special offer is available
here at this link drink
lmnt.com Tim that's drink element Again
drink
lmnt.com Tim
this episode is brought to you by
Shopify Shopify is one of my favorite
companies out there one of my favorite
platforms ever and let's get into it
Shopify is a platform as I mentioned
designed for anyone to sell anything
anywhere giving entrepreneurs the
resources once reserved for big business
so what does that mean that means in no
time flat you can have a great looking
online store that brings your ideas
products and so on to life and you can
have the tools to manage your day-to-day
business and drive sales this is all
possible without any coding or design
experience whatsoever Shopify instantly
lets you accept all major payment
methods Shopify has thousands of
Integrations and third-party apps from
on-demand printing to accounting to
Advanced chat Bots anything you can
imagine they probably have a way to Plug
and Play and make it happen Shopify is
what I wish I had had when I was
venturing into e-commerce way back in
the early 2000s what they've done is
pretty remarkable I first met the
founder Toby in 2008 when I became an
advisor and it's been in spectacular
I've loved watching Shopify go from
roughly 10 to 15 employees at the time
to 7 000 plus today serving customers in
175 countries with total sales on the
platform exceeding 400 billion dollars
they power millions of entrepreneurs
from their first sale all the way to
full scale and you would recognize a lot
of large companies that also use them
who started small so get started by
building and customizing your online
store again with no coding or design
experience required access powerful
tools to help you find customers Drive
sales and manage your day-to-day gain
knowledge and confidence with extensive
resources to help you succeed and I've
actually been involved with some of that
way back in the day which was awesome
the build a business competition and
other things plus with 24 7 support
you're never alone and let's face it
being an entrepreneur can be lonely but
you have support you have resources you
don't need to feel alone in this case
more than a store Shopify grows with you
and they never stop innovating providing
more and more tools to make your
business better and your life easier go
to shopify.com Tim to sign up for a one
dollar per month trial period it is a
great deal for a great service so I
encourage you to check it out take your
business to the next level today and
learn more by visiting shopify.com Tim
one more time shopify.com Tim all
lowercase
at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half mile before my hand starts
shaking
questions
[Music]
living tissue over metal endoskeletons
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is Tim Ferriss welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss show this is
a rare in-person episode and my job
always is to investigate interrogate
people I consider to be world-class
performers I have one in front of me
he's a friend he is a repeat guest a
very popular guest Jack cornfield you
can find him on Twitter at Jack
cornfield jacktrained is a Buddhist monk
in the monasteries of Thailand India and
Burma that's an understatement but maybe
we'll come back to that he has taught
meditation internationally since 1974
and is one of the key teachers to have
introduced Buddhist mindfulness practice
to the West Jack co-founded the Insight
Meditation Society in Barrie
Massachusetts with Sharon Salzburg and
Joseph Goldstein and Spirit Rock Center
in Wood acre California current projects
include cloudsangha.com which we will
talk about which offers practice groups
for all the mindfulness meditation
teacher certification program which has
trained seven thousand seven thousand
that's a lot mindfulness teachers in 75
countries and wisdom Venture is a fun
investing in companies that promote
compassion his books many books have
been translated into 22 languages and
have sold roughly 2 million copies they
include the wise heart a guide to the
universal teachings of Buddhist
psychology a path with heart after the
Ecstasy in the laundry one of the best
book titles of all time Buddha's little
instruction book The Art of forgiveness
loving kindness and peace and his most
recent book no time like the present
finding Freedom love and joy right where
you are you can find all things Jack at
Jack cornfield.com that's
k-o-r-n-f-i-e-l-d.com and we'll link to
of course all of his social and
everything else in the show notes to not
blog slash podcast Jack so nice to see
you I'm very glad to see you Tim and I'm
glad that our lives have now intertwined
over a number of years so it's been a
pleasure in all these different venues
it has been a pleasure you have been a
safety net a mentor guide
a field EMT perhaps with some of my
situations over the years and I really
appreciate it it's my pleasure to we do
it for each other the triage the wisdom
the teaching and there are a million
different directions we could go but
before we started recording we were
chatting a bit I was making my tea
asking about good departure points
perhaps the initial liftoff where we
should go
and we landed on a name and that's Stan
Groff so perhaps you can take that and
lead us wherever you may providing
context on who this is why it matters
why it relates to your life and so on
yeah thank you Tim and I wanted to do
this in some way because Stan Groff in
the scene that I want to set for you who
are listening opens the doorway to a
huge number of really interesting
questions about who we are about
Humanity about healing about
interconnection about all kinds of
things so here's the scene Stan Groff or
stanislavgroff as he is sometimes called
is a Czech born physician and
psychiatrist who was the last legitimate
LSD researcher in the 1970s he'd done
LSD research in Europe got samples from
Sandoz and took some himself and it
completely changed his life from being a
kind of academic physician to say whoa
there's something a lot bigger going on
here and he ended up at Johns Hopkins
when he escaped from the Communist
Regime running the last LSD research for
people who had cancer and were in
hospice were dying for vets returning
for clergy so that they might actually
have a little experience of the Divine
that was off the pages of their texts
and and so forth and then he moved after
that to be at esslin for a long time we
collaborated there together for about 20
years
over the course of our time to get to
the story and he's a polymath speaks you
know 12 or 15 languages and reads
Sanskrit and is completely well versed
in the European education of the great
music of the world and all kinds of
things like that so when it became less
possible to work with psychedelics
except a bit underground he developed
with his wife Christina holotropic
breath work which allows people to go to
some of those very profound open States
using breath and it mirrored things that
I'd learned in Monastery in Burma where
we've done incredibly intense deep
breathing for some hours and open to all
kinds of States we worked together at
Retreats all around the world and we'd
be in a room with
200 or 300 people huge speakers I think
the Grateful Dead or something like that
um half of the people 150 lying on their
backs on a nice mat and then a sitter
next to them
and then the music would start with the
instructions very simple instructions
breathe as deep and fast and hard as you
can and keep it going for the next hour
or two until for liftoff till you go
wherever you go so people would be
breathing away and there would be this
incredible music it might be drumming
from the African musicians in the Congo
drum jungle or all kinds of world music
and as you looked out over the room once
the breathing had kicked in after half
an hour or an hour
it was like walking into
Dante's Divine Comedy it has heavens and
purgatory and hell and so forth so there
would be people
in Bliss laughing smiling their arms
spread like they were angels having the
most ecstatic experiences there would be
people in the middle who were working
stuff out with their bodies things that
were tight that would want to open and
every kind of possible sound would come
there were a lot of people in a birth
experience because like psychedelics of
different kinds
one of the doorways you go through is in
your regression is to relive your birth
and so there would be people pushing and
being squeezed and going through a
process that was both physical but more
than that it mirrored what their birth
was like and then there would be people
reliving incredible traumas of different
kinds birth traumas childhood traumas
and so forth
and they were encouraged to go through
it and let it all out there would be
laughter there would be the sounds of
ecstasy and there'd be people crying and
screaming and you'd all at the same time
with this pounding music and you go like
what is this
the result of it to kind of cut to the
chase once the music quieted down and
people were invited to make some art and
then talk about it
is that and Stan's work is this if you
trust the body and psyche and heart and
mind to open and you give it the
opportunity and the medicine and
someone's with you so you're not alone
it wants to open and whatever's
unfinished wants to come out or whatever
needs to be expressed and if there isn't
something that's waiting there then it
becomes the doorway to the Realms of
profound both Awakening Freedom
understanding beautiful things and one
of the great sayings that Stan offered
is we all began this Collective Journey
was from our friend Joseph Campbell the
great mythologist who said if you're to
do this inner work
you either need a very big story
like the vastness of the universe that
has what we could see in front of us
heavens and Hells and you know the
hungry ghosts and the jealous gods and
everybody all enacting it either you
need a very big story or even better no
story at all and this scene was really
the scene of the gateway to the human
heart and the human psyche this is who
we are what we carry
and then we shrink down a bit as we need
to in our roles to be a parent or a an
artist or a business person and so forth
but they're really kind of a contraction
of this enormous spirit that we were
born with and that we carry so how's
that for an opening scene The Divine
Comedy of expansive States I think it's
a great place to start and I'll add just
a few things to that and then I will
have numerous questions that come to
mind so the first is for people who may
wonder about the scope of Stan's
experience he's probably in some way
directly or indirectly supervised
at least 1500 sessions I remember when I
spoke with him quite a number of years
LSD sessions yeah thousands of thousands
yeah so the breadth of experience that
he has in witnessing
in a clinical setting how these things
affect Consciousness and also outcomes
is vast it's really vast
the second is whole Tropic breath work
for people who need just a bit more in
the visual
in terms of conjuring an image of what
you just described the pounding music
really can be pounding music it's really
can be very very loud
and I've had some really bizarre
experiences
going through holy breath work which I
don't do that often and I may be doing
something incorrectly but I tend to have
speaking of pounding a pounding headache
the day after from the breath work
however
I've had some really unusual experiences
that I didn't go in trying to confirm so
I didn't go in with the expectancy of
these experiences but later I was told
that it was sometimes referred to as a
yogic sleep maybe you have some thoughts
related to this but the experience of
breathing as hard as I can I take these
directions very literally so I'm really
going for the gold medal of of heavy
breathing
sweating profusely and
having the experience of
subjectively
a gap in time where I haven't fallen
asleep in the physiological sense that
most people would
conjure but I've gone blank and then I
come to and I'm still breathing as
intensely as I was but I had these gaps
that would pop up repeatedly
do you make anything of that
there's a beautiful old
yogic text that details eight kinds of
yogic swoons
not a word we use very often but
basically it's description of what it's
like to leave our ordinary Consciousness
and either go to a place where it's at
the void where there's nothing or the
sense of profound emptiness but there's
still some awareness there's a variety
of them and some of them have a huge
impact on us when we experience it it's
as if oh the whole world that we've
constructed is a little bit like a dream
and we'd step out of that dream of our
identity and here we are coming back
into the stream and it puts in an
incredible perspective reasons a lot of
questions also whether it's in my
experience that I described
certainly you can have some interesting
responses with say tetany and the the
lobster claws from the breathing when
the hands get pulled in you start
puckering at the mouth just
physiologically due to various changes
in the blood but and I should note for
folks I have
quite a few friends who have trained or
done weekend courses in holy Trope of
breath work it is not standard that
people have headaches afterwards I
haven't experienced that for whatever
reason I just drew the Joker card on
that but I have found it very helpful
I've also experienced with breath
workers
in Baltimore specifically the approach
of holotropic minus 40 intensity you can
still seemingly reach some very let's
call them alternative experiences of
Consciousness but if we put that type of
practice aside even my experiences in
some cases with say surgeries and
anesthesia where I'm given a push of
versed before I go under and the last
thing I remember is them asking me to
switch from say a gurney to a table but
they afterwards tell me that I was
conversing freely following directions
cracking jokes for 20 minutes afterwards
which I have no recollection who was
that who was that exactly who is that if
the primary Observer that I have sort of
constructed as this identity of the self
was not that laughs who was that so if
you look back at your life you've had
some
very unusual experiences from the
vantage point of let's just say most
westerners who are raised in the secular
society without mindfulness practice
you've spent a lot of time in silence
you've had the experience of
metabolizing your anger wrapped in all
sorts of clothing and we've explored
these in previous conversations we
probably won't get into all the weeds
but how do you think of
this is a big question but consciousness
as it stands right now or is that a bad
question it's a central a really
important question and kind of
connecting it with starting with that
scene of seeing Dante's Realms all laid
out and the people you know in ecstasy
and those in agony and everybody in
between one more thing to say about it
because some people say well that's too
fast if you've got a trauma and it's not
right of course nothing's right for
everyone but there are two ways to go
with this one which was Stan's way is
just as you said go for the gold just
keep going and the people he trained to
sit with you if something was opening up
and it took a long time they would take
all night and sit there with you as you
breathed or screamed or wept or just lay
there quietly until you felt you had
been able to experience it all and come
back to a place of presence now some
other people say oh you have to Resource
the trauma away you have to get more
quiet and strengthen yourself before you
even approach that's better for you
neither of these are the right way but
I'm glad there is this spectrum for me
entering that room or doing that work
throws me into the place of being the
conscious witness of it all
and my deepest experiences whether it's
through long meditation I spent more
than a year in silence doing this little
Hut doing intensive meditation 18 20
hours a day or whether it's psychedelic
experiences which were equally profound
or other things who we are is
consciousness
and there's a couple of levels a lot of
levels to it one I can say you're not
your body clearly your physical body
changes all the time so it's not who you
are you rent it you get to use it you're
not your emotions they're always
changing like the tide you're definitely
not your thoughts at least I hope not in
those cases certainly for me and people
I know
who you are you could say is the
Consciousness that was born into your
body and that will leave it and we could
talk about death and how Consciousness
leaves but there's a deeper level than
that to know that not only are you that
as consciousness
but more profoundly
it's all Consciousness that at the
deepest level what I've experienced
is that there is whether you call it
primordial Consciousness or a field of
Consciousness that the creative
principle that creates all things and
where a piece of that or a part of that
and they're all kinds of beautiful myths
that talk about how Consciousness wants
to explore all the possibilities it can
be or it is the creative of the universe
there's the void and then out of the
Void comes creativity and all these
Myriad forms when you experience this
and it's not a philosophy you understand
that this is a play the Hindus call it
the Leela the play of the Divine or
something like that and it doesn't mean
you don't have to take care of your part
the play is in theater the play is in
theater the play of the Divine and it
doesn't mean that you don't have to play
your part as ramdas would say you know
remember your true nature
and your Social Security number right
you have to remember both and that's
part of the very interesting Paradox of
waking up knowing that what you are is
consciousness itself you are awareness
you're not all those other things you
are the awareness that's experiencing
these things when you know that it gives
you a kind of Freedom a sense of
well-being and freedom within which you
can go through all the things you do as
a human being but some part of it behind
that is smiling and going wow I hope I
say this when I die like wow what a ride
you know that it's been quite and some
of it is painful and tragic but with
that perspective there's a place of
wisdom I'm going to read you something
it's just a not very long a few lines
all the time in the world if you don't
realize the source
Consciousness you stumble in confusion
and sorrow
when you realize where you come from you
naturally become tolerant
disinterested
amused kind-hearted as a grandmother
dignified as a king
immersed in The Wonder of the Dao you
can deal with whatever life brings you
and even when death comes it's okay you
are ready
and so it's a kind of 3 000 year old or
2000 year old description of the
Consciousness where you're both
disinterested and amused and at the same
kind-hearted and and attentive and it's
the wedding of that universal dimension
with this mystery of actually being a
human being which is what you've done
then you can enter or you go to Japan or
you say all right let's let's play this
game let's do martial arts let's do
business but you do it with less fear
and attachment and much more with the
Delight of the game
right it makes me think that you're to
come back to the play term
you're aware of the movies that you are
watching or the games that you are
choosing to play but you have that
outside witness perspective so that you
don't necessarily identify or grip to
strongly onto those things exactly and
that includes your own personality and
again I just because I I'm thinking of
him in this regard refer to ramdas he
talked about his personalities being
like his pet you know and he would see
his neurosis and he said you think that
getting wiser and more enlightened that
all would go away he said it doesn't
he's just I've adopted it's my path I
feed it I say thank you you know but I
know it's not who I am and from that
place
even the kind of great suffering that
many of us have in our lives the people
that we love who've died and unless we
can hold it with great tenderness but
it's not a surprise it's like oh
this too this is part of what it is to
be human and you know someone dies in
from that perspective it was their time
so quick question for you related to the
Joseph Campbell quote that you mentioned
earlier
I'd love for you just to elaborate on
that a little bit maybe what it means to
you that you either need
a really big story right one of maybe a
cosmo Vision or a mythology or better
still no story story at all what does
that mean to you so I have a friend
Roger Walsh MD PhD who's on the faculty
of Stanford Medical School written a lot
of books as both a Mystic and uh
psychiatrists and other things and being
somewhat scholarly he decided to read
through the entire Encyclopedia of world
religions from ahura Mazda all the way
to zoroaster and everything in between
underachiever exactly so I said to him
afterwards I said Roger you read the
whole damn thing what did you get out of
it and he said
what I saw is that every religion has a
story
of the origin of the world
it is a story of some kind about how to
navigate gain and loss praise and blame
you know good and bad he said usually as
a story about death and afterlife
they're all very different stories
they're quite compelling they're all
different stories and when I was
finished I realized
human beings need to tell a story and
place it on top of the mystery
because without the stories then we
would be in the present with the mystery
of being alive with the universe but for
most of us we want a story and so these
are the big stories that Humanity has
written hmm what is the alternative of
no story because when I think of no
story
that actually strikes Terror into my
heart because I imagine this
free-floating
nihilism or meaninglessness and I
understand
experientially in some of these
alternate modes of experience through
psychedelics and so on that you can have
the experience of no story no time no
name no self yes I understand that
or I should say I understand that I've
experienced it I definitely can't claim
to understand it but what does the
alternative mean to you well this is
really important because it's as if
you're talking to some Zen monk
somewhere and they talk about emptiness
and you go oh it's like how do I
deal with that how do I you know buy a
new car or how do I you know take care
of my family or things like that
so it's a really important question and
there are a couple that we've talked
about number of levels one level is the
more opinions you have about the way
things are
the more trouble you have and one of my
favorite passages the Buddhist texts
aren't really full of a lot of jokes and
humor but there's one place where the
Buddha says and those who cling to their
opinions go around the world annoying
one another you know and that's that's
an observation that holds true thousands
of years later like Twitter so we know
that the more we're attached to our view
because whatever you're thinking or
whatever you view there is an
alternative it's not the only view so on
this level what my Korean zen master
desonsinim said is to keep a don't know
mind or Suzuki roshi calls it beginner's
mind where you meet somebody fresh where
you go into a circumstance first so
that's part of not having the story but
it's a much more positive cast on it
then the second is that without having
that story then it's replaced in somehow
by
a sense of I don't know quite words
Wonder value meaning a sense both of the
vastness of things and also the Delight
in being incarnated as a human being and
so with that like the Tao de Ching says
you remember the source which is you are
Consciousness that's who you are and you
get to witness this you are the
awareness the loving awareness then your
story might be all right I am the loving
awareness as you know as you are as
everyone who's listening you are loving
awareness and you get to then embody and
enact in this world
and then you get to choose how and it
turns out in
our direct experience that there are
ways we can act that bring
understanding connection joy happiness
well-being and ways we can act that
create suffering in the Buddhist
teachings that Buddha said I do not
answer philosophical questions people
with all these what's the first
beginning what is all the meaning of
karma how all of this what's the story
and you would say I just teach how human
beings can release themselves from
suffering and fear and confusion and
live with the innate Freedom that is
their Birthright that's what I teach
that is a story it's my favorite story I
think in this life because there is
suffering and difficulty in Incarnation
there are causes that human beings
can understand
and there's Freedom when Nelson Mandela
walked out of Robin Island prison after
27 years that's a long time you know
that's was half his life in that prison
with such magnanimity and graciousness
and compassion he not only changed to
South Africa but he somehow changed the
imagination of the world they can put
your body in prison but no one can
imprison your spirit or your
consciousness
and when you know this deeply then there
comes a different innate kind of story
which is one more deeply of
connectedness and care
stingroff to return to our dear friend
stanislav yeah has written a lot of
books you mentioned he's apologize he
truly is and he's prolific also in his
writing
there is
one book it may be two volumes and I
can't recall offhand called The Cosmic
game one volume that caused me one
volume all right why does this book of
all of his books
grab your attention or why is it
meaningful it does I'm glad you named it
because he explores the very questions
you're asking not only who are you but
he also shows
suppose we were to have a world that
didn't have lost didn't have conflict
didn't have
disease didn't have the kind of troubles
that we live what would that world be
like and he explores and you kind of
follow along with his exploration
how it is that the world that we live in
somehow has been manufactured and in
some way what there is to learn from it
and what's beautiful about it is that he
says I think in the beginning that he
took the records from 5 000 LSD sessions
and from the deepest understandings in
the height and a lot of the people who
did those sessions were also people who
were already meditators or yogis or
martial arts Masters or in some way and
Shaman people who had already a very
deep spiritual perspective and he
collated them and he said here's what we
as human beings when the gates between
the worlds open this is how it looks
which which is really compelling he's so
clear that he doesn't want to say this
is how it is or how I think it is he
said this is what 5 000 people report
from the height or the deepest of their
experiences and you go oh yeah I've seen
that I know that that's true
all right I need to dig back in and get
into the cosmic game so I'll get that on
my Kindle for my upcoming travels
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show this episode is brought to you by
ag1 the daily foundational nutritional
supplement that supports whole body
health I do get asked a lot what I would
take if I could only take one supplement
and the true answer is invariably ag1 it
simply covers a ton of bases I usually
drink it in the mornings and frequently
take their travel packs with me on the
road so what is age one ag1 is a science
driven formulation of vitamins
probiotics and Whole Food sourced
nutrients in a single scoop ag1 gives
you support for the brain gut and immune
system so take ownership of your health
and try ag1 today you will get a free
one-year supply of vitamin D and five
free ag-1 travel packs with your first
subscription purchase so learn more
check it out go to drink
ag1.com Tim that's drink ag1 the number
one drinkag1.com Tim last time drink
ag1.com Tim check it out
let's talk about
something perhaps that many people
listening will identify with or at least
recognize in their daily experience and
that is
anxiety and maybe we could just Define
terms
and look at anxiety as
fear of the future you could also Define
it differently could be
pre-experiencing the worst case scenario
I really don't know how you would like
to Define it but
if you wouldn't mind digging into that
and share any approaches that you think
are helpful
practices
thought exercises for people who are
suffering from anxiety that would be
very helpful I was gonna say that word
before you said it so we're somehow
writing some current we'll see where it
takes us and if we're still on in the
same boat as we go through the wrap
learning how to paddle we'll see and
anxieties are big but also a really
important question and the first thing
to note is that we're living in a time
of tremendous cultural anxiety even in
places where there was Warfare or
starvation or things when there were
very small groups of people there was
still a kind of basic I know who my
family is I know where the land is you
know we'll have the food or we won't but
everything is up for up in certain ways
there's a kind of upheaval now of
identity where we live who we are and so
forth that's accelerating and it's been
accelerated of course for all kinds of
things and now we'll get to it certainly
been accelerated by technology and we're
on the cusp on the roller coaster ride
you know the click click click as you go
because you're going up to the top right
and the little sign that you've got your
ticket for said ai go go on this ride so
we'll get to that
but anyway so there there's the anxiety
there's the economy anxiety there's the
collective anxiety about climate there's
racial and economic Injustice that's
really in our Forefront and then there's
the human anxiety of our own family and
people going through things of
loneliness and economic insecurity so
first thing to say there's a whole bunch
of things that might be helpful the
image that I like to start with is an
archetypal one of the Buddha seated
under the tree of Enlightenment the
night of his Enlightenment before
he was enlightened the Indian God named
Mara who is the god of
greed fear hatred aggression all of the
forces of suffering appeared
and said what are you trying to do to
the Buddha and this is the way it
appeared he said you have no idea what
you're dealing with and he said let me
show you this Enlightenment stuff and so
he paraded before him all the most
beautiful dancing bikinis and gilded
chariots the Lamborghinis of the time
and the Buddha said you know been there
done that thank you okay
and then he said well you you know you
have no right to be there and he started
throwing flaming arrows and swords and
the Buddha lifted his hand and touched
them all with compassion and they turned
to flower petals cool then Mara said you
don't even know who you are you don't
know what you're doing and there's no
reason for you to be sitting here then
Mark came basically in the form of doubt
and at that point the Buddha put his
hand down and touched the Earth and said
will you bear witness to my right as a
human being here halfway between Heaven
and Earth to awaken to the way things
are can you say that one more time
Heaven and Earth are Heaven and Hell
Between Heaven and Earth we didn't get
to Hell yet you want to go there we can
go there later right between halfway
between Heaven and Earth in this human
form be my witness that we human beings
have the right to see clearly not with
delusion not with doubt and then Mara
appeared again and the Buddha just
looked at Mara and said
I see you Mara I see who you are and the
minute he said that clearly Mara
dissolved now what people don't know in
the Buddhist text is that after his
Enlightenment Mara came back to visit
the Buddha quite a few times you think
there's enlightened retirement but but
Mars part of the game and take not
Hannah is a really beautiful image about
this where he sets the scene of the
Buddha sitting in a cave and again the
Buddha really is a stand-in for your
awakened self sitting in a cave mouth of
a cave meditating in his attendant as
they are in Mara appears and his
attendant tries to chase Mara away and
the Buddha says Ananda is that my old
friend Mara set out some tea let us sit
down and he says is that you Mara and
usually all that it takes is for the
Buddhist say is that you Mara or I see
you Mara and Mara looks and kind of
sadly slinks away if you will so the
first thing about anxiety is to
acknowledge that it's entirely human
that there are cultural reasons for it
and that their physiological reasons
that we have fear and we have fear of
loss and all of those things
and to be able to name it and say oh
this is anxiety it feels this way in my
body your hands sweat your breath stops
your heart and it's hard to feel it's
unpleasant in the body
and then it has its thoughts we'll get
to those in a minute
and what you can do in naming bar you
can say oh anxiety I see you I feel you
so that's the first thing and already
you start to step halfway back from it
as the witness so that already begins to
liberate you a little bit
and then the next thing is you can also
say
thank you for trying to protect me
because if you fight against the anxiety
what that is is more anxiety oh my God I
got a Ritter I hate him but instead it's
almost like you take a little bow okay
Mara I see you thank you for trying to
protect me because that's what it's
trying to do and you remember that
statement from Mark Twain where he said
my life has been filled with terrible
misfortunes most of which never happened
right so these are the stories human
sort of the advanced stories say thank
you Mara I see you thanks for trying to
protect me then the next thing is to
know that there's something called the
wisdom of insecurity that it's actually
okay to be insecure my monastic teachers
would say it's uncertain isn't it we
could ask them all kinds of things tell
me about Enlightenment my teacher would
laugh he said it's uncertain isn't it he
wanted us just to get comfortable with
uncertainty that's and then what happens
is when you realize that you can't know
that you come back into the present
moment and then the next thing to do
with anxiety is ground your senses feel
your feet on the floor or maybe go out
in nature or stand there with a tree
feel the roots of the tree and imagine
your own feet as roots into the Earth
and notice the wind comes and the storms
and all those things happen but the tree
is rooted and it can stay there and you
can be the same you can let the storms
of thoughts and fears and so forth arise
so that's another practice you can do
then you can
question your thoughts and this is more
the beautifully spelled out by Byron
Katie for example who has these
practices of questioning your thought
says what if that thought isn't true how
can you know that thought is true and if
you look deeply you can't know it and
you get to a place of realizing that
your thoughts are tentative their
creation when you say thank you thank
you for trying to protect me and again
you become the witness of those thoughts
then a few more very simple things that
you can do
you can find where you feel the anxiety
most strongly in your body and once you
feel it you can feel into its elements
is it hot or cold is it hard or soft is
it vibrating the earth air fire so you
really get close into it you can ask it
what stories it tells because it'll have
a story and then you say again not only
thank you thank you for trying to
protect me but you wrap it with kindness
with loving awareness and say thank you
I know you're worried I can respect you
and hold you with kindness and
compassion
and you know that that's not who you are
this is a part it's something it's
common for human beings you say I
respect this and who I am is honoring
you it's so much bigger than Who You Are
and you feel yourself literally being
both the witness the grounded one the I
know you my I see you Mara and you
become more the Buddha rather the one
who's caught by all these things could
you say a bit more about asking for
instance in this case
the anxiety what stories it tells maybe
give an example whether from your
personal experience someone else's or
just a hypothetical what that might look
like that's the first time I've heard
that and
that piques my curiosity so it's a
beautiful question because one of the
things that I've learned all over these
years is that you can have the sufis
call it a so bad
a conversation with the heart
and if you let yourself get quiet it
might be after a little walk in the
woods or just sitting quietly taking a a
cup of tea or something that you like to
drink and letting yourself quiet down or
meditating if you want to
and when you get quiet you can have an
inner conversation and there's
information that's waiting there for you
to ask
so for example since we're talking about
anxiety and you want to have a
conversation with it you can say to the
anxiety where do I feel you most
strongly in my body okay that's a pretty
simple one
then you can say ask the anxiety
what is the thing you're most afraid of
usually it will be something like loss
of death something huge okay thank you
get quiet and say tell me the story you
have about it
and then your anxiety will answer and it
will say well if you lose your job which
we're afraid you will you'll be out on
the street you'll be homeless people
will beat up on you then you'll be in
the hospital or you'll become whatever
and there's a whole disaster scenario
and you can say yes thank you I hear
your story then there's another
interesting question so all these are
things you can ask and if you're willing
to ask and get quiet and listen usually
your body and your heart will answer
then there's another really important
question or two that you can ask what is
the most important thing
I need to learn from you
and it will give you an answer
I want you to pay attention or I want
you to take care of your financial
affairs so I don't have to worry so much
you know or I want you to make sure you
have friends who know where you are
whatever it happens to be or some bigger
story
and then you can step out of the anxiety
and this is a really beautiful one and
get quiet and ask what is my best
intention of how I want to live this
next month or this next year if I only
had a year to live
what style how do I want to live this
because anxiety also has time in it and
so you're sort of stepping out of time
to say all right so my time's Limited
how do I want to live what is my deepest
intention
and if you pause and ask
your heart will answer
so this may tie into my next question it
might not but you mentioned this MD PhD
earlier and you said as you told the
story of his digesting this
encyclopedia you said end a Mystic and
then you moved on to say what you said
and since you mentioned Sufism that also
brought the word Mystic or mysticism to
mind for me what does that mean to you
someone being a Mystic
I'm afraid that it's sort of gotten
relegated to the realm of religion okay
the sufis have their Mystics and they
were the Christian desert father Mystics
or the Zen Mystics or something and
that's true these are people who are
really interested in some way in vast
spiritual experiences and understanding
but it puts it outside of ourself we all
in that sense are open to mystery when
we quiet how the hell did you get into
this body you know you take a look look
in the look in the damn mirror do these
weird round things that we call eyes and
protuberances from your head that stick
out mind stick out pretty far my ears
got made fun of as a kid you know you
opened your mouth and the tongue comes
out and there's this hole in your body
into which you keep stuffing dead plants
and animals and grinding them up with
these bones that hang down right and
glugging them down through the tube and
you move it the weird watching how
people you fall One Direction buy Peds
and then you catch yourself and you fall
the next verse how did you get in there
and if you don't think that's weird pay
attention when you're making love it's a
fabulous thing to do I'm completely you
know love it
it's bizarre it is okay you know
whatever way you do it licking putting
this in that part of that body or that
and so forth and a little whatever I
mean it's weird and so how did you get
in here so we don't have to go to the
Sufi Mystics or the or the whatever it's
really more mystery is the mystical in
this sense and this is my placeholder
way of thinking about it the direct
experience of the mystery or seeking the
direct unmediated
experience of that mystery is that one
way to think about it yeah that's I mean
that's a nice way to say it I might want
to change the word seeking to opening to
it and just to be really direct with you
who are listening
you know what I'm talking about
you have had experiences whether it's
walking in the high mountains
or taking psychedelics and meditating if
that's your wand or your Avenue you had
it listening to an amazing piece of
music or going into an incredible
Cathedral or a forest of the Sequoias
and redwoods of Wonder or you know it
from making love
you know it even more from being there
at the birth of a child
he wrote whoa here's a whole new human
being and my beloved wife Trudy Goodman
who's is also a meditation teacher in La
inside La is her Center
she was 21 years old she was giving
birth to her daughter and by
circumstance she was in a hospital room
alone it was like in the 60s and it was
the old style birth basically and they
left her alone and she had no idea her
body just started Contracting and going
through these incredibly painful and she
didn't understand it in a deep way at
all no one had sort of explained how it
happened she said and then all of a
sudden
it was late afternoon it was in what the
french color blue the blue hour of kind
of transition between day and night
she said and all of a sudden it wasn't
my body my body was doing its thing
delivering this child but I became
all mothers I could feel that I was in a
chain of being that went back
to A Million Lives before one mother
after another birthing people out of
their body and would continue and there
was this incredible sense of being part
of this huge mystery of life recreating
itself
she said afterward I was walking down
the street I looked at all these people
I say they all came out of a woman's
vagina you know how could that be I mean
so you want to look at mystery it's it's
staring Us in the face
we are that don't have to be a whirling
dervous you don't have to you don't have
to be willing to every sister there are
all kinds of ways so we all know this
from somewhere and even more associating
with someone when they die because there
you are especially if it's a reasonably
conscious or peaceful death that person
is there
and you might be able to talk to them or
there's some sense of them being
conscious
and then as quietly as a falling star
Consciousness leaves the body
and it's meat it's just dead you know
it's like at the butcher I mean I'm
being really graphic but that's all it
is is this cold you know flesh it's so
clear that it's not that person and you
go whoa the gates between the worlds
have opened like who are we so you want
that baby it's around you it's here
yeah
okay okay I think we're at an
intersection okay where I'm gonna bring
up something just opportunistically
because it's on my mind
and this has somehow popped up on my
radar
I want to say at least twice I don't
know what it is I literally have a
Wikipedia page open but why go on
Wikipedia when I have you right here
and you could use chatbot it would
answer but anyway I could use a chatbot
I could use a chapter human chatbot will
speak go ahead yeah that's right so you
know why use AI when you can use organic
intelligence
Janna practice am I pronouncing that
correctly yes what is Jana practice okay
so John I practice now you're getting
down in the technical weeds of certain
kinds of Buddhist practices
I know okay so one of the things that's
true about the dimensions of deep
meditation practice is that we human
beings have a capacity to concentrate
our attention in meditation practices
there are two major Dimensions one is
the dimension of awareness it can be
mindfulness or devotion or something
were you open to the mystery of things
unfolding thoughts appearing emotions or
you create certain emotions of love
compassion Joy all of those things the
other is the dimension of concentration
where you focus deeply on one thing
generally it can be a candle flame or a
mantra or a particular emotion like love
or your breath
and there's a beautiful biblical phrase
where it says if thine eye be single
then the gates of Heavens open or
something like that when you start to
get very concentrated
several things happen
your thoughts start to disappear
to be concentrated means you're focused
on an experience like the breath or a
light
and the thoughts quiet down and
gradually they go away not easy to do
for most people but it's possible
and then as you get more concentrated on
the breath or a mantra or whatever
you've chosen and you do it over and
over again it becomes a doorway the next
thing that happens is that inner forms
of light will appear so there you're
sensing your breath we use that as an
example but it could be other things and
as you do the thoughts start to get
quiet and then the sense as you feel
your breath is not only is there breath
but around your nostrils or your throat
or your wherever you're paying attention
your body
and the the field
starts to fill with light because
Consciousness is made of light so light
will appear and then with it
comes quite spontaneously qualities of
deep joy and happiness and incredible
steadiness and inner peacefulness and
when these qualities start to arise they
are the gateway to a whole series of
what are called johnnas or samadi states
the deepest ones you no longer see or
hear what's happening around you you're
so absorbed in the light or the Bliss or
the sense of peacefulness and well-being
that everything else disappears and
you're in a realm that's just filled
with light and Stillness and peace and
you can move around from one realm to
another several different flavors of
them the closest thing I can describe to
it is if you're a diver and you're out
on the water and there's waves and the
sun shining and things and then you go
under the surface of the water
and everything becomes silent you know
there's waves on the surface they have
nothing to do with you and instead
you're in this vast Timeless Silent
Realm
purpose of training to go into these
kind of states is twofold one is it
gives you some skill in navigating in
your Consciousness and mind so you don't
have to live if there's a lot of
whatever it is anxiety or conflict or
things around you you can actually
stabilize yourself become quite stable
it gives a kind of Faith oh the Mind
actually can be trained but the other is
that from that Stillness then you can
see or listen more deeply to concentrate
is a little bit like polishing the lens
of Consciousness so that whether it's a
microscope or a telescope when you're
very concentrated at the beginning you
notice their thoughts then you notice
the thoughts at the end and you're more
concentrated you notice at the beginning
of the thought oh it's about to arise
then you notice the impulse for thoughts
to come it's like a little burp that's
coming out of the brain you know and
then you see the space around thoughts
where they're born before they're even
there and then you look into the body
and it first you receive hot or cold and
then it pixelates with deeper
concentration and you see all the
elements that make it up so this is like
the microscope or you point it outward
and Consciousness becomes vast like the
sky and there's no bounds to it it's
Timeless so these kind of states of
Consciousness give you access to the
telescope and the microscope and the
information that comes through that
doorway how's that that's great you had
me at pixelate so another question about
this and I suspect we've talked about
nobody ever asked me this on the air
before so this is fun okay yeah so let's
let's go so I hear your description
and it grabs my attention and interest
and I would love to experience these
states I consider myself good at being a
diligent practicer so I've trained in
sports I've done many things
consistently over extended periods of
time
my felt experience of meditation is that
it's done regularly on a daily basis in
small doses I experience and improved
quality of life decreased reactivity but
I doubt my own ability to reliably
achieve the type of states that you're
describing which is part of the reason
and now I'm not married to that belief
but I think part of the appeal for a lot
of people with say psychedelics is in
most cases with sufficient dosing you're
probably going to feel something
yes and that is not to say that should
be
the soul tool or that people should be a
hammer looking for nails with
psychedelics because there are risks and
trade-offs and so on that is just a very
long-winded way of asking to get to a
point where you would feel reasonably
confident that someone could achieve
these types of states are we talking
about five years 10 years 15 years in
some instances is like 10 people pursue
this they do it for 10 years and then
only three of them experience these
states I fear the possibility that I
would dedicate to a long-term practice
and then for whatever reason just not
have the capability
so now
this is a really important question it's
more than about Jonna sure even though
I'm happy to talk about it because it's
fun to talk about I'm also a little bit
reluctant because it can mislead people
or feed into a kind of spiritual not
spiritual materialism but idealism of
some kind okay I've heard about these
states and then or you go and you read
this end stories and okay then they
worked on their koan and finally whacked
the master hits them and then they have
this great Revelation or other things
like that John is completely unnecessary
for wisdom it's the kind of thing that
yogis and people who devote themselves
to meditation some of them can do some
can't it depends there's sort of light
levels and then very deep levels of this
if you want to do a light level genre
there are several ingredients one is you
probably have to have a certain
temperament or inclination to be able to
do it and that's probably you know a
third of people not everybody can do it
and then you need to go on Retreat if
you want deep genre you need to go on
Long Retreats just because I know your
reference point might be different than
a month or two months or three months
long practice if you want to have some
kind of initial experience a good friend
of mine a colleague named Lee brazington
leads 10-day Retreats and you can have
an experience and it's fun to play with
it's completely unnecessary now I want
to talk about Enlightenment because the
point of all this is if you divide it
there are experiences and then there's
understanding or being and the
experiences that we have you mentioned
psychedelic experience which which I
deeply respect
whether it's John experience or deep
insight and meditations of different
kinds that we do or other spiritual
experiences you can be the dervish as
you mentioned whirling and it's such a
beautiful thing to see and to do and the
world starts to dissolve most of these
practices dissolve the separate sense of
self and you're there as
Alice Walker wrote of one character one
day I was sitting there like a
motherless child which I was and it come
to me that feeling of being a part of
everything and I knew if I cut a tree my
arm would bleed and I laugh and I cry I
run all around the house in fact when it
happens you can't miss it so there are
all these doorways that open us beyond
the separate sense of self in which that
sense of small self it's sometimes
called the body of fear that limit
itself dissolves
Hallelujah they're great I played with
John I've taken psychedelics I've done
shamanic things all these I've had a
bunch of experiences and part of it
gives me a kind of confidence okay I
know this territory
part of it is deeper than that in the
most profound places as we talked about
I know that who I am is not this body I
know that who I am is consciousness
then the game is not about the
experiences it's about
who you are who I am as we manifest in
the world
and the way that I most Express
Enlightenment at this point
is not somebody who's had a lot of these
experiences
in all these years my understanding
really is that it comes down to love
I've met swamis and llamas and gurus and
Mamas and everybody else in between in
my industry and some of them are
fabulous but there's a really
interesting thing that you can have
these powerful experiences and still be
a little bit of a jerk just getting real
about it you know is it because
our Consciousness is like a mandala and
we can awaken some dimensions of it so
you have an Olympic level athlete who's
an emotional idiot you have a professor
of nuclear physics most brilliant and
she can't find her shoes or her body we
can develop ourselves in some areas but
it turns out unfortunately that doesn't
always go over to another area and so
there's a kind of halo effect where
people think oh this person is a
spiritual teacher and they've had these
spiritual experiences I'll go ask them
for marriage advice
or advice for sexuality they don't know
about marriage yeah so this is our
human nature if we're actually to become
wise
we need to direct our attention to body
to emotions to relationships to thought
we actually need to become wise in those
major dimensions of our life and we
can't expect that of people just because
they have a certain title or robe or
anything else
but having said that my measure now for
myself
are you loving am I loving are they and
that love isn't just like oh sweet
Valentine love but it's can you be in
this world and can you love it with all
its imperfections and can you bring that
Spirit of care and love in the middle of
what's tragic and what's beautiful
that's a liberated heart
so love let's underscore this for people
who are listening this might sound like
a really strange question
who are thinking of themselves well I
love my dog
I love cheesecake
love my kids if they have kids let's say
but maybe they're like I'm not sure
if I would recognize or even know the
feeling of what it is to love the world
maybe they feel like they might be
colorblind to the first person
experience of feeling that is it just
something they can Intuit or could you
expand on that you remember Einstein
said that the task for Humanity is to
widen our circle of compassion or you
could call it love to include all of
humanity and all of nature in its beauty
and so we start by loving that which is
right around us it's natural your dog
you know your children the partner the
people you care about and maybe your
neighbors
and now we're talking about well what is
wisdom and what is Liberation and it's
that widening of the circle so that when
you're
moving through the world
it's not just that person over there as
an object but they become more and more
a part of your family
there's a beautiful Monument to a
mystical experience going back to your
asking about that in Louisville Kentucky
on I think it's on 4th Street Fourth and
walnut and the great Christian Mystic
Thomas Merton left his Monastery and was
walking down the street in the middle of
Louisville and he said I come from the
monastery we were all trying to be holy
and close to God and have all these
spiritual experiences the way one does
and pray and so forth and I was walking
down the street and all of a sudden it
came to me I looked in the eyes of
everyone going by and I saw their secret
beauty that was born in them that no one
can take from them
that magnificence of spirit Soul
whatever you want to call it he said the
only problem would be I wanted to fall
down at their feet and worship each one
that went by he said if we could see
each other that way there'd be no more
need for war and cruelty the world would
be a different place so this Monument a
public monument to a mystical experience
what it does is it says that this is
possible but more than that there are
beautiful trainings to do it one of my
favorite trainings is trainings in
loving kindness meditation there's
Bunches of it on my website and Sharon
Salzburg and tari Brock and lots of
other colleagues and teachers and it
turns out if you practice it like
anything
it grows you start with people close to
you and then those in a little Wider
Circle and gradually extend it and for
me for example I'm out on the street or
I'm driving or something and I'm a bit
of a speed freak you know I can sit
quiet indentation but my my general ammo
is to get stuff done and move throughout
you know and so if somebody's driving
slowly and Meandering and not being a
good driver in front of me and I get
annoyed or even on the sidewalk people
are blocking it not aware that I have
something important again
whatever and I feel a little moment of
irritation arise which it will
I look
and I see them not as they are now but
as they were at three as I imagine them
at three or four years old completely
innocent child you know they all were
that no matter what things happen to
them
and I go oh yeah I see who's in there
that's like emergency I see that there's
that person doing the best they can and
there's that child that's in there and
instantly my heart changes and I go oh
yeah I wish them well may they be safe
and whatever dance they're in may they
be protected and this quality of loving
kindness and compassion it's grown
because I practice it some it's where I
want to live but it's more than that
I see it or sense it as the best
expression of Enlightenment all those
other things are experiences they lead
us back to love and if they don't I'm
not sure that they matter that much and
we can learn it and become it so would
you suggest maybe people use this
objective or Beacon of Love versus
Enlightenment as a term because the word
Enlightenment has always bothered me
because I've never had someone to find
it clearly for me in any way let's call
it in loving men I just made it up but
perfect okay great problem solved where
problems we're into enloement we have
problem solved I also wanted to take a
side note because
Joseph Campbell came up earlier and he
has so many tremendous books and one of
them is called I believe it's the power
of the animal spirits which is this
anthropological and historic overview of
animal mythology cross cultures it's a
beautiful hardcover book it's gigantic
it's absolutely spectacularly
Illustrated with drawings and
photographs and so on just to come back
to the why you wouldn't ask your fill in
the blank right that your psychedelic
practitioner automatically for marriage
advice for instance
across the board shamans in almost every
culture pretty much considered pains in
the ass
trickster troublemakers and here you are
aspiring to be a shot in trouble oh no
I'm not I'm not I'm not in the shaman
MBA program at present
rule number one of tracking down shamans
if they call themselves a shaman be very
very very cautious might want to run the
other way it's kind of like if you meet
the Buddha on the road kill him kind of
situation but let's shift to a moment to
wisdom and
I would love to ask you and this is a
question that you can feel free to
dissect in any way that you like but who
would you consider some of the wisest
people you have met and
why and or what have you learned from
them I could certainly go down the list
and I'll answer you explicitly and then
there's some place I want to go from
here but I studied with a guru in Bombay
named nisargadot Maharaja and there's a
wonderful book of his or dialogues with
him called I am that
n-i-s-a-r-g-a-d-a-t-t-a he had a little
like Beady cigarette stand he was a kind
of modest business person but he had a
wonderful Guru that he met and he had
some profound realization happen to him
and so groups of us would gather around
and
one day when I was with him over a
course of a few years I would go and
visit him somebody says you're 80 years
old he was sort of getting toward the
end of his life what do you think about
your approaching death the kind of thing
you want to ask a guru and he looked
back completely affronted and he says
you are telling me I will die
and the person said well aren't you he
said that's just this body it's made of
you know japatis and wheat flour and
vegetables and subject you think I am
Joe it's like saying I'm made of
McDonald's is that who you think I am
you think I have these feelings you
think I am you know these thoughts you
have no idea that I have this has
nothing to do with me I was never born
and I will never die Who I Am is beyond
birth and death I am the Consciousness
from which everything is born
and then later he said wisdom says I am
nothing love says I am everything
between these two my life flows so he
was a pretty wise cat yeah solid
response and take not Han said sort of
the same thing as he was dying people oh
God Ty as they called him you're gonna
die and he said I was never born look at
a rain cloud and it comes down as
raindrops or snowflakes and goes into
the rivers and flows into the ocean and
then the gets evaporated and becomes a
cloud again you think I can disappear
I am you and you are me we are life
itself unfolding and it's one thing to
have him say it but was another to be
with him and have him look you in the
eye and say this is Who We Are
so there are of course there's all these
beautiful examples what are the most
reliable
approaches for eliciting the experience
the direct experience of
non-self and I say that because I don't
recommend everyone use psychedelics
there are a lot of footnotes to any
conversation on these compounds which
are so powerful
but that is how I've had my most direct
experience of what you're describing
which has removed much of my
fear of physical death
I fear the dissent to death that's still
there but in terms of the light switch
being flipped and being turned off I
don't have that much anxiety at least at
present related to that and I haven't
for quite a while
a whole trip of breath work might be
another tool are there other modalities
that you think apply or could be applied
to more people than
powerful psychedelics of course I mean
psychedelics they open a lot of doorways
and they also need to be used with some
discretion and some caution or
discernment as you say it's just not a
you know and definitely not just like
okay let me take a high dose psychosolic
and see what happens you want set and
setting it has to be appropriate for you
all of those sort of things it's really
what we've been talking about that
there's a worldwide treasury now we live
in the treasury of the great spiritual
teachings and practices and you can go
online and find Masters and you know
sages and llamas and Mamas and so forth
many of whom are really really good how
do you separate the charlatans from The
Real McCoy though this is it's just like
I don't know I'm gonna sort of like
shopping for a car you know the minute
you walk in if it's a sleazy sales
person
showroom and it feels like this doesn't
feel like it's a you can go somewhere
else but there are so many Jokers with
large followings out there oh yes well I
really are um any any suggestions for
the Intrepid I'm basically who's looking
for a llama I'd say probably start with
the name brands although there's plenty
of very widely known llamas and swamis
and mamas who've also misused their
position what a good teacher wants is
your dedication and your common sense
and if the common sense is thrown out
it's the wrong place for you you really
have to trust yourself as well
now you were asking about wisdom I want
to read you a few lines from a great
Indian master named atisha and they're
really instructions because you say okay
how do we do this yes you can find
practices meditations think Reflections
walking in the in the wilderness things
that will open your mind in your heart
here's a tisha's instruction in
something like eight lines and they
really each is a kind of practice the
first one consider all experiences to be
dreams that there's a dream like nature
and it is true I mean here we are you
and I are talking in April
2023 what happened to March what
happened to January what happened to you
know your childhood where did it go what
happened to do you remember Y2K what
happened to 200 it's back with the
pyramids and the dinosaurs everything
disappears back into the void from which
it came and then something new is born
it's the reason why people keep writing
love songs it's not like there haven't
been a lot of good love poems but the
universe wants to keep recreating itself
all the time
that's why your body creates a hundred
billion red cells every day red blood
cells the universe is a is a process of
creation
but it also is like a dream because it
appears today is here and it will be
gone like your life of this kind will be
gone at some point so consider all
experience to be dreamlike
next one be grateful to everyone
so that's an instruction and it sort of
fits with this
other instruction let suffering teach
you compassion
because in Tibet in some of the Tibetan
teachings they actually pray for
suffering they say may I be granted
enough suffering so that the great heart
of compassion will open in me
so consider all experience to be dreams
be grateful to everyone because they all
have a lesson to offer you might be an
unpleasant or painful lesson
let suffering teach you compassion
next line don't be swayed by outer
circumstances this is a tough one they
want you to be this and that and all
that conditioning and you can see it and
you can use it but don't let it guide
your life let your life be guided when
you get a little quiet by your own
values in your own heart
a few more lines I love this one don't
brood Over The Faults of others I could
do some work on that one yeah this one
can save a lot of Agony because people
don't act the way we want them to and
they all have their faults not not us of
course don't root over the faults of
others you can feel how there's
Liberation in every one of these lines
and you can practice it
explore the Timeless nature of
Consciousness which is what we've been
talking about
two more things at all times simply rely
on a joyful mind and we'll talk about
joy in a minute joy and Community too
there are things I want to talk about
and then the last line I really love he
says don't expect a standing ovation
how do you spell Leticia
a-t-i-s-h-a oh man that's great you know
don't expect and it's like we're looking
for the universe to affirm us the
universe has affirmed you baby you
wouldn't be here otherwise don't expect
the standing ovation so those are all
you're asking how we do it those are all
actually practices they're instructions
in some way and you can take one or
another this year I'm going to practice
being grateful for everyone the ones
that are difficult I remember when my
daughter first got her one of her first
jobs you know and she was complaining
about she liked the work and she like
but the man manager sort of the middle
level boss was not good he was a tyrant
he didn't organize things that God is so
bad we need to get rid of him I said
Caroline welcome to the world of work
you think there's a bad boss there try
another job there will be someone he's a
stand-in for the archetype of you know
the Bad Boys you will find them so you
got to figure out how to deal live in a
place where and not brood over it where
people are just that way yeah joyful
Minds I could always use more joyful
mind so Joy or joyful mind
how should we find our way into this
vast subject which I think all listeners
could certainly
use a bit more of yeah I want to repeat
something that I believe I might have
said in a previous podcast with you but
it is one of the great poems of the last
decades in My Mind by Jack Gilbert and
it's particularly so
because
we at this time those who you and I and
those who are listening not only is
there the mystery and incredible beauty
of life with all its sorrow it still has
this unbearable Beauty in so many
directions but we also carry in our
heart the suffering of the world we can
talk about that and how one holds it but
this is a poem called a brief for the
defense the defense of what you might
ask by Jack Gilbert
sorrow everywhere Slaughter everywhere
if babies are not starving someplace
they're starving somewhere else
with flies in their nostrils
but we enjoy our lives because that's
also what the gods want
otherwise the mornings before lavender
summer Dawn would not be made so fine
and the Bengal tiger
orange and black would not be fashioned
so miraculously well
the poor women at the fountain are
laughing together between the suffering
they've known and the awfulness in their
future
smiling and laughing while somebody in
the village is very sick
if we deny our happiness
resist our satisfaction we lessen the
importance of their deprivation
we must risk Delight
we can do without pleasure seeking but
not Delight not enjoyment we must have
the stubbornness to accept our gladness
in the ruthless furnace of this world
to make Injustice the only measure of
our tension is to praise the devil
if the locomotive of the Lord runs us
down we should give thanks that the end
had magnitude we must admit that there
will be music despite everything
and so that's a line to make Injustice
the only measure of our attention is to
praise the devil we must have the
stubbornness to accept our gladness in
the ruthless furnace of this world what
is the name of that poem one more time
it's called a brief for the defense by
Jack Gilbert and it really speaks to the
tearing open of the heart in our time
that we have the suffering of the world
and it's presented to us if we don't
have it in our family or in our
neighborhood it's there on our screens
and it's there given to us how do we
hold it and is it okay
is it okay to be happy and the Buddha
put it the same way he said live in joy
and love even among those who hate
there's an instruction yes that's there
live in love even among those who hate
live in joy and health even Among The
Afflicted live in joy and peace
even among the troubled and I was like
my teacher's Monastery during the war
time in Cambodian loss in Vietnam it was
a place of Peace in the middle of all of
that
live in peace even among the troubled
look within be still
free from fears and attachments know the
sweet joy of living in the way
so these are really instructions
permission people think spiritual life
is a grim Duty I'm going to meditate I
go to the gym I work out I have a diet
you know I've got my trainer I've got a
now I gotta go and meditate and it's not
meant to be a grim duty if you don't
have some joy and pleasure in it you
know that's the wrong direction baby
it's really an invitation to quiet and
calm to bring in care and compassion if
you go into a refugee camp
they don't want your depression and
sadness they have enough of that they
actually want somebody to come in and
say Hey you know let's see what we can
do with this even though it's incredibly
difficult
so building on that
and also off of the previous mention of
holding suffering
I'd like to shift to community and the
timing is perfect for that
looking at my personal experience
because I've been in Los Angeles for a
few weeks
and I made a commitment to myself which
is very atypical for me because I have
this productivity fetish and I should
put productivity in quotation marks
whatever that means
but I decided that my mantra for this
time here was going to be social not
solo okay and
that meant rather than doing what I
normally do which is default no to any
type of social invitation I made it
default yes and my well-being my
sense of inner peace is so much improved
since I started doing that now granted
my output is lessened substantially but
at this point who cares I think on some
level
and it's highlighted for me how even in
a city for instance could be anywhere
any City it's possible to be surrounded
by people but feel entirely alone and it
takes some intentionality perhaps
to build and be supported by community
so maybe this is a place to talk about
cloud sangha.com
Cloud song up but we could lead into it
in any way that makes sense to you yeah
I welcome this as part of our
conversation first of all there is an
epidemic of loneliness as you point to
it the Brits have their minister of
loneliness now and I think it's even
gotten more extreme since brexit in some
way they actually got lonely from the
continent sadly but anyway from the very
earliest understandings there's a
teaching or a pointing to the fact that
we need each other in community whether
it's the
Jewish Minion or whenever two or more
gathered in his name whether it's the
satsang in Hindu or the Sangha in
Buddhism or within a community in a
village around a teacher or a shaman or
and so forth we're communal beings
we're raised by one another we're
connected and so we languish when we
don't have connection one of the great
problems in the current time is that
there had been a a way that many many
people had a sense of community Through
religious affiliation for Generations
before their Church their mosque their
Temple whatever it happened to be that's
dropped away a lot for all kinds of
reasons and it's left people more
isolated and so together with tarbrock
and a couple of friends we founded a
company called Cloud Sangha s-a-n-g-h-a
Sangha which means communitycloud
Community dot Co
and you can join for a month or several
months to start with and become part of
a group
of people who meet together every week
around themes that you're working with
we have groups for anxiety and how
people are managing and learning about
it and transforming it we have groups
for people who are parents you know and
in those groups you can talk about
whether it's you know your toddler's
tantrum or your teenagers acting out or
whatever it happens to be we have groups
for people who are interested in
promoting joy in their lives and groups
for those who are dealing with grief or
loss and those kind of things and people
who join them love them
because you can be living in Boise Idaho
or Belfast Ireland or whatever and it
can be hard to practice on your own it's
hard to meditate it's hard to feel a
sense that you have a kind of community
who are supporting you and what happens
is as people come together and share
they learn as much or more from
themselves together as From Any teacher
you know I've done the stage on the
stage thing a lot in my life and yeah I
can put on a good act or show or
something and sometimes it helps people
I love telling stories and I remind them
and so forth but when we're in groups
one of my favorite things to do is to
say
what have you all learned about this
somebody will raise their hand and say
what about grief or what about climate
or what about how do I and if I respond
what have you all learned there is a
collective wisdom when invited that
comes out where people learn so much
from each other and this is really what
cloud Sangha offers it also has if you
go on to
cloudsonga.co for the fun of it there's
a test you can take a mindful awareness
test to see just for your own fun which
areas are you really attentive in your
life and which ones you really you wish
you had support for and it would make
such a difference when we've got great
people running them and people who are
in them love them so it's one of the
offerings in my life now that I'm very
really happy to be a part of and want to
invite people to try
are there practices
tools and so on that help people to
sharing communal experience what are
people finding most gratifying so there
are a couple of things there are some
practices and there's teachings and you
can go on that and there will be guided
meditations and there's weekly teachings
by several variety of good teachers but
it turns out people will come together
and for example it will be a Groupon
parenting some are doing a mindful to
this practice maybe some are doing some
other form of meditation they learn TM
or maybe they they've been doing a
Jewish or Christian practice or shamanic
practice or something but there they are
and their toddler is having fits
screaming is toddlers sometimes do as
they're supposed to and the common
element is much less the focus on what
you're practicing is how do you engage
in the world from that place of practice
and people will say well I meditate and
it helps me be calmer with my kids and
surprisingly when I'm calmer my children
get calmer you know or they say when my
teen is pushing back you know if I get
into the conflict mode with them it just
builds but if I do my practice of loving
kindness or I do my practice of whatever
it happens to be
and I look at them and I see their
secret Beauty especially it's a
beautiful thing to do when your kid is
sleeping there you've had a little
conflict you know at that age and then
you go in there they fell asleep and you
go look at them they and you see who
they are who they were as a child you
know there's there's something that
original beauty is there when their
personality drops away a little bit but
they share that and it's less critical
what the practice is and much more how
are you applying it and what are we all
learning in doing this and this is where
the rubber meets the road in some way
and again it goes back to that
definition of enloement or enhartenment
or something that's not Enlightenment
but how do we learn to love in the midst
of all of this
I've come to feel I'm excited about this
because I have realized for myself if I
have
and I realize it's not the same thing
but group dinners with
let's just say three friends two three
nights a week that does just as much for
me maybe more in some cases than short
meditations on a daily basis just having
that support I'm not saying they're
mutually exclusive I do both as of right
now but that social cohesion for us
monkeys on the spinning Rock in the
middle of the cosmos
is easy to perhaps forget in the
frenzied individualistic
prism within which we live inside the
United States it's easy to forget
the value of something that is so
obviously in front of us but so often
lost in the wake of in my case this
quest for productivity and
so many other things so I'm excited to
take a look at this myself cloud
sangha.co and the spelling again for
folks Cloud
s-a-n-g-h-a dot Co I have some notes in
front of me and this has been something
on my list to ask about and maybe you've
already brought it up it certainly
includes a name that has already come up
so ramdas
formerly known as Richard Albert
flunking the course ramdas and flunking
the courses is a cue that I have in
front of me what is flunking the course
refer to so romtas was a very close
friend for a lot of years and I've known
him in his different incarnations when
he was Baba ramdas just back from India
having written that bestseller be here
now that opened a lot of people's eyes
about how he'd been the Harvard
professor and then he took LSD and said
oh whoa things are that's a bigger game
than this and then he met his Guru in
India and all of that and he came back
in his robes in his beard and Beads as
sort of the guru Baba ramdas and one of
my favorite early ramadas stories is
there he was teaching a whole crowd and
he was articulate and funny and very
self-deprecating you know which is part
of why we loved him because he would
confess his Neurosis publicly and
everyone would go oh me too right
because we need there's a common
humanity and one woman was sitting in
the front row an older woman and waved
her hand and said hey ramdas he said he
called she said hey there you are in the
white robes and doing this whole Hindu
Guru thing aren't you Jewish and Ramada
said well well yes I was born Jewish I
was bar mitzvahed she said so what about
it and he said well there's beautiful
things in it there's the Kabbalah and
all the mystical teachings and there's
the Hasidic Masters who are like Zen
Masters it's there's a lot that's great
in it and then he looked at her and he
said but remember I'm only Jewish on my
parents side
and he was very witty but it was also
profound because who we are is not
limited by our parents or our history
who we are is much bigger than that so
remember
evolved over his life starting save a
foundation and you know working to
combat blindness into Paul and India for
now six million people who've been blind
can see and all kinds of other stuff
and then he had that major stroke
and ended up living 20 years in a
wheelchair with tremendous pain and you
know different kind of infections but he
came more and more and more loving so
when you'd sit with him toward the end
of his life he'd look around he said I
love it all I love the windows and I
love the floor and I love the people who
come in and I love you know the dirt he
said I just love it all whatever it is
and people would come to see him he
would love them and there's a phrase in
India called the glance of Mercy when
you go to see your Guru if you go to see
the right kind of Guru but it doesn't
have to be in India can be here they
look at you and they it's somehow they
see through you they see all your life
your you Tim you know your strengths and
your neurosis and your productivity you
know the rat and the wheel going around
making it spin faster all that all that
stuff and they look at you with so much
love and they say wow you're just
amazing being and you get this glance
that see sees everything and says yes I
love you and it changes you somehow and
that's what ramdas became in the end
Krishna does the great chanter and you
know also a fellow student of their Guru
named Corolla said ramdas became in the
end the person we thought he was when he
first returned from India he really
became that place of love now I've gone
on and on and I haven't answered your
question because I've forgotten it as
I've been waxing about
flicking flinking the course oh yes so I
went to see ramdas
after I had a
a couple of events where I fell over on
stage and was unconscious for a while
and opened my eyes eventually and you
know are surrounded by all the doctors
who were part of the audience and so
forth and then I got all these work ups
and I had a lot of Tremors and I got
misdiagnosed
as having something like ALS I was gonna
die relatively quickly and I would have
dementia with it
I thought I'd made my peace with dying
okay I'm gonna die but then when they
said oh yeah and dementia too that
flipped me over the edge I didn't that's
not how I had pictured it and I got
frightened really
and I remember sitting in with my
daughter after I got that and crying a
little bit and thinking okay you know
here we go into dementia land along with
tremors and my body going out of control
and then you know a couple weeks later I
got more tests and turned out that was
the wrong diagnosis and I'm okay I'm
fine you know I'm just aging like
everybody but I went to see ramdas and I
told him that story and I said I thought
I was cool with death I'd done all these
meditations in the monastery sitting
with dead bodies and my own practice and
then when the dementia came in I got
frightened and he looked at me he
laughed and he said oh yeah I flunked
the course a number of times and the
minute he said it it was like this huge
relief because it was just being human
and our body doesn't want to die even if
you know like you said it and I think
it's true that we've prepared ourselves
in some ways but the body doesn't want
to die it has its own story so ramdas
represents for me and I think for us
that loving witness that can Wing can
say wow we really got into a predicament
this time didn't we and it's okay it's
just a dance that we're in and it's fine
he did have a real facility
for combining humor with the profound
and really pithy short
statements it's remarkable yes he did
I've been listening to some of
his audio recordings there's a podcast I
can't recall the name which which is
effectively sharing archival audio Yeah
I think it's probably the be here now
Network that's it that's exactly it and
what incredible Communicator I mean
incredible human I never met him but uh
incredible incredible humor and twinkle
and Sparkle and yeah all those good
things and yeah he was human too so he
had his own foibles and the thing that
was most beautiful about it is that he
would make them all public
he would say all right here's where I
messed up this week and everybody would
smile and say oh you know like just like
me I remember at some point and I'm not
going to be getting this totally right
so you can correct me I don't speak
Sanskrit or can't read Paulie or
whatever it might be but my
understanding is that ramdas Das is the
equivalent of servant of right rum and
then you have Krishna
Krishna right so is Das simply is it
just a common suffix and therefore
that's it or is there deeper meaning
behind the choice I don't know if they
made it or their Guru or someone else
made it of Krishna and RAM respectively
Guru gave them their names looked at you
and said you serve Ram you serve Krishna
you know there's this whole the cool
thing about the Hindus that they have so
many gods you can sort of pick your
favorite and the way it works I mean the
the problem is that we have God as a
noun that's singular God okay and then
we fight over it my God is realer than
your God or better than your God or
bigger than your whatever you know my
God can beat up your God whatever it is
in the in all these different Traditions
all that you need to do is add an S
there is Yahweh or Jehovah or whatever
and there's Jesus and Jesus and there's
you know there's also other versions of
God there's Krishna and Brahman and if
you allow as the Hindi is do that the
Divine has many names
and many forms instead of fighting over
and say let's celebrate okay so Das
means the servant and I don't know who
you served him but um you could be uh
sure yes I need a guru to tell me what
my name is
anyway no one of my teachers was named
Buddha Das he was the servant of the
Buddha or the Buddha's teachings or
things like that so it's very very
common
and for those who end up digging into
Stan Groff and some of his writing he
has some really fun stories around the
servants or worshipers of Shiva and his
interactions with them which is a whole
separate can of worms okay and Stan also
has a book when the I think it's
something like when the miraculous
happens it's his stories of all the wild
things that happened in his life that
were completely unexpected and that you
can't put into ordinary Consciousness
just like we've talked about it before
I've had the experience a number of
times of knowing that someone died at a
distance and not necessarily that they
were ready to die or you know they
didn't have cancer but I knew it they
had an accident Who would know that and
then I reach out and I found out yeah
they had an accident and then I'll ask
in a room of you know 100 or 500 people
how many people have had the experience
of knowing when someone's died you know
unexpectedly
and a third of the hands go up and it's
because we're connected it's just the
reality of it so I want to talk about
climate and Justice and one of the
teachers that I most admire who's in her
90s now and still alive is Joanna Macy
she wrote a wonderful book called world
as lover world as self and she's been
doing what she calls Despair and
empowerment work for decades now and she
did I remember her going and meeting in
the survivors of the Chernobyl nuclear
disaster and at first they didn't want
to talk to her they said why are you
rubbing our noses in it you want to calm
you American and you know we've already
had such a hard time why should we talk
about it all again with you and she sat
and listened she repeated back what
she'd heard and you said the only reason
I really want to talk to you beside my
sympathy because I too am a mother and
grandmother she said
is because I don't want this to happen
to other people's children and you have
a story that the world needs to hear
and then they wept and they said all
right we'll tell you the whole story
so she's collaborated for years with
others in doing this work that she calls
Despair and empowerment work and she
describes it this way she said we're in
a time of what she calls the great
turning where Humanity has the capacity
and tools to make the world and how we
live a beautiful place or not things
have gotten bad and it's not just a
disaster it's also an opportunity and we
can all feel that in some fashion or
other
so her game is first to get people to
feel the grief and the anger and the
guilt and the despair
and to share it with one another so you
don't feel alone
and that you can sense that you're part
of the Web of Life That's responding
just as if you've cut your hand or your
finger you didn't say oh that poor hand
is if it's separate from you it's part
of this your body that people could
start to feel that they were together in
the body of the Earth
holding this and responding and she said
all right now let's listen more deeply
and one of the things that she did with
a environmental activist named John seed
they created something called the
Council of all beings and on those
Retreats after expressing grief and
despair and holding it with compassion
and feeling the interconnection of the
earth alive saying we need to do
something people would be sent out into
the woods for half a day
to wander the woods in the streams with
the instruction
to sense
whose voice you want to carry who you
wish to be a representative of and it
might be someone you meet out there or
it might be that it inspires you
people came together and sometimes they
even in a shamanic way would make a
drawing or put something on their body
that represented what they wanted to do
come back in circle and then they would
speak but not as themselves
they would say I speak for the Redwoods
or I speak for the salmon and I want you
to know that most of my people have died
off because of this and that happening
and this is what I want you to hear I
speak for the you know and you can name
the species or the the part of the Earth
and what would come out of people was
tender
Grievous at times but also tremendously
inspired because those voices said
here's what we need to do this is what
we salmon ask of you and you can do this
you know this is what we the sakuras and
redwoods want of the world now and so
she shifts the despair
to a sense of interconnectedness and
that we become the voices of the Earth
in its most benevolent and best form
and it seems important to say this
because you know we started talking
about anxiety long ago in this
conversation as we wended our way
through all kinds of strange places and
this takes us back to touch on that
and the important thing is to know that
suffering is not the end of the story
it's the first Buddhist first truth that
there is suffering and there are causes
we can see it greed hatred fear and so
forth and there's an end to it there's
another possibility which is the
empowerment of Love of action and part
of what makes things liberating and this
has to do with compassion and empathy
is not only what you feel but then what
you're empowered to do when you speak
for the salmon or whoever it is so
here's the difference between compassion
and empathy if you're walking by a
schoolyard and you see a child being
bullied
the first experience inside might be oh
I feel for that child that's wrong I
feel they're suffering so you have a
kind of connection an empathetic
connection with that child all
I'd hate to feel that I don't want
children to feel you feel with them
come means with with passionate that's
not enough compassion it turns out as a
verb you have the first step is empathy
the second step in compassion is
you walk over and you talk to them or
you go to the teacher or you go into the
office and you say you know the kids on
the playground are bullying people you
not only feel it
and you let yourself enter in a
communion if you will with what you see
but then something in you feels
empowered to say
let me reach out my hand you don't have
to fix the whole world but you can reach
and mend the places that you can touch
and it doesn't have to be a lot and just
like you come to LA and decided to be
social rather than solo and it makes a
difference
reaching your hand out and touching or
doing something
empowers you and it changes the world
I think that's tremendous place to
leave people with that as a closing
comment for food for thought is there
anything else though that you would like
to add
Jack oh maybe a hundred and eight other
things
but this feels like a wonderful
conversation and also a kind of
expression of our friendship for a long
time I'm glad to see you and see you
seeming so well I certainly know when
you describe that you're in new phases
in your life in different ways and I can
very much appreciate that and I've had
fun and you know as I said it's not a
grim Duty it's actually a celebration it
is a celebration and I think I'm going
to also
set the a brief for the defense the poem
by Jack Gilbert as a reminder so that I
re-read and reread and reread that it's
a really potent reminder and I think
it's it's catching me at a good point in
my life so hopefully that's true for
other people as well
Jack people can find you online Jack
cornfield that's the k k o r n f i e l
d.com Twitter at Jack cornfield
Instagram Jack underscore cornfield they
can find Cloud Sangha at cloudsonga.com
and we will link to everything that
we've talked about in this conversation
in the show notes for people at tim.blog
slash podcast and they just can search
your name in the most recent episode
probably unless we do more of these and
someone's listening to this a few years
later they'll be able to find with ease
thank you Jack thank you Tim what a
pleasure so nice to see you what a
pleasure and to those listening until
next time be just a little Kinder than
is necessary to others and to yourself
and remember that compassion can begin
with feeling but can also incorporate
and often should incorporate some form
of reaching out some form of connection
some form of action and thanks for
tuning in
foreign
like to do a guided loving kindness
meditation practice
there are many many versions of it
you can find them online from Sharon
Salzburg and
Tara Brock and Joseph Goldstein and many
many other teachers
and this will be one version and you can
see what works for you
there isn't a right way to do meta
sometimes the practice of cultivating
loving-kindness is just to radiate love
without words
sometimes it's to begin by holding
yourself with kindness again and again
and tonight we'll use one of the classic
practices which also involves the inner
recitation of phrases of well-wishing
toward others and toward yourself
and it invites in whatever way you can
the quality of kindness the images and
the words are an Avenue to opening the
heart but the most important thing is
not to use it to judge yourself
sometimes it feels beautiful
sometimes it's so so you know how
meditation goes sometimes it's
frustrating you know it brings up its
opposite how can I feel love I'm so
angry at that person
and then what do you do when you feel
that
you hold that too with compassion and
kindness
if it feels mechanical you hold that
with kindness you just receive what
arises and trusts that the field of
kindness itself
is what matters
so sit comfortably it's hard to do
better loving kindness practice if your
body's
your knees are killing in your backs
aching so you want to be a little bit at
ease
and let your eyes close gently
for the next one
25 minutes or so
first
as you settle yourself
Let the Body relax
at ease let the eyes and face be soft
loosen the jaw
maybe roll your head in a circle a
little to release your neck
let it find the
simple upright
let the shoulders relax
in the arms and hands rest easily
heal yourself Seated on the Earth
halfway between Heaven and Earth in this
human form
let go
rest where you are let the Earth
completely hold you and support you
let the belly be soft and the breath
natural
and let the heart be soft as well
so that you invite a quieting of the
mind and
tenderizing of the heart
and the blessings of loving kindness
often recited before one begins the
meditation
are that it is uh an antidote to fear
and anxiety
when we enter into the loving and
trusting heart
that when we cultivate loving-kindness
others will love us more commonly and
animals will notice in care and
elephants will bow as we go by it says
children will be happier around us and
will be happier our dreams get sweet our
thoughts get easier
we become more gracious with the
difficulties of life
as we open the heart
now I'll take two long breaths
breathing in and out deliberately and
quite slowly
letting go whatever wants to release
to be open
present
and now in this
present moment
letting yourself settle
and setting the intention
to awaken the field of loving-kindness
let yourself think of or picture
remember
someone that you care about where it's
easy
not a conflicted relationship but
someone or it's easy to feel a natural
care and love
it doesn't have to be some super thing
it's just whoever evokes a sense of
kindness in you and caring
couldn't even be your dog
when you remember or think of this
being likely a person
that you care about
feel the Natural Care
do you picture them remember them
then begin very simply
whispering
phrases
of well-wishing inwardly
may you be
filled with loving-kindness
Maybe
safe and protected
fulfill your care as you say these
things
may you be well
and strong or healed
be aware of the
struggles in their life the measurable
struggles like all human beings
and feel the tender compassion that
comes
with what they struggle
may you hold your struggles and
compassion
on The Underneath It All may you be
happy
maybe filled with loving kindness
may you be safe and protected
may you be well and healed
strong
may you hold your struggles
with compassion and tenderness
may you be happy
peaceful and happy
feel the natural well-wishing
as you see them
now pick a second person or second being
where there's a natural
caring and love again uncomplicated and
easy
as you remember and picture and sense
them
think of them
offering the same well-wishes
may you be filled with loving kindness
may you be safe and protected
maybe well
and healed
strong
may you hold your struggles with
tenderness and compassion
courage
and may you be happy
truly happy
now let yourself imagine picture
that these two beings that you care
about
are there in front of you gazing back at
you
with eyes of kindness
for they want to wish
for you the same loving kindness you
extended to them
and together they gaze at you
and they whisper
may you two be filled with
loving-kindness
receive it imagine
their blessing their kindness toward you
they want you to have this
may you two be safe and protected
feel their care
they say may you too be well
healed and strong
may you two
hold your struggles
with compassion and kindness
and they gaze that you may be happy
like blessing you may you be happy
amidst it all
and you take in these
phrases and words of loving kindness
and recite them for yourself if you like
you can even put your hand on your heart
and just as they wish for you these
people who you care about
they care about you as well
may I be filled with loving kindness
as they wish
may I be safe
and protected
may I be well
healed and strong
may I hold my struggles with compassion
and courage
may I be happy
free and happy heart and spirit
filled with loving-kindness
safe
protected
may I be happy
now without any more words from me
let yourself go through
two or three or four more people that
you care about or people that you know
or people who are struggling
or Beyond them you can spread your
loving kindness out to groups of people
places in the world where they're having
difficulty to refugees
to children
women
beings
but start a little closer to home
do a couple or a few more people you
care about and then become a beacon or a
lighthouse and spread it more broadly
using your own phrases and well wishing
spread the meta the loving kindness
like light
far and near near and far
as you extend the loving kindness
you become the beacon of kindness
the beacon of loving kindness
yourself
and all that it touches
take one more minute
whatever invites the spirit of loving
kindness
for yourself
and other beings
invited now
now keeping the spirit of loving
kindness
allow your eyes to open gently
and sense that you can inhabit the
consciousness of loving kindness
eyes open wherever you go
one of my ways of practicing this is to
see the child in each person around me
especially if I'm going about on errands
and I see somebody who's
having a hard time or making a hard time
getting pushier aggressive or whatever
and I look and I see them and I try to
picture them as a child as a young child
with a certain innocence and their
struggles as children have
and know that that child of the spirit
is still in there somewhere
it brings the loving kindness alive for
me
whatever the principle of matter is to
do it in whatever way most feels natural
to you
in whatever way allows you to see with
the eyes of tenderness and compassion
and kindness
find your own beautiful way
hey guys this is Tim again just one more
thing before you take off and that is
five bullet Friday would you enjoy
getting a short email from me every
Friday that provides a little fun before
the weekend between one and a half and
two million people subscribe to my free
newsletter my super short newsletter
called five bold Friday easy to sign up
easy to cancel it is basically a half
page that I send out every Friday to
share the coolest things I've found or
discovered or have started exploring
over that week it's kind of like my
diary of cool things it often includes
articles I'm reading books I'm reading
albums perhaps gadgets gizmos all sorts
of tech tricks and so on that get sent
to me by my friends including a lot of
podcasts guests and these strange
esoteric things end up in my field and
then I test them and then I share them
with you so if that sounds fun again
it's very short a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend something to think about if
you'd like to try it out just go to
tim.com Friday type that into your
browser Tim dot blog slash Friday drop
in your email and you'll get the very
next one thanks for listening
this episode is brought to you by
Shopify Shopify is one of my favorite
companies out there one of my favorite
platforms ever and let's get into it
Shopify is a platform as I mentioned
designed for anyone to sell anything
anywhere giving entrepreneurs the
resources once reserved for big business
so what does that mean that means in no
time flat you can have a great looking
online store that brings your ideas
products and so on to life and you can
have the tools to manage your day-to-day
business and drive sales this is all
possible without any coding or design
experience whatsoever Shopify instantly
lets you accept all major payment
methods Shopify has thousands of
Integrations and third-party apps from
on-demand printing to accounting to
Advanced chat Bots anything you can
imagine they probably have a way to Plug
and Play and make it happen Shopify is
what I wish I had had when I was
venturing into e-commerce way back in
the early 2000s what they've done is
pretty remarkable I first met the
founder Toby in 2008 when I became an
advisor and it's been in spectacular
I've loved watching Shopify go from
roughly 10 to 15 employees at the time
to 7 000 plus today serving customers in
175 countries with total sales on the
platform exceeding 400 billion dollars
they power millions of entrepreneurs
from their first sale all the way to
full scale and you would recognize a lot
of large companies that also use them
who started small so get started by
building and customizing your online
store again with no coding or design
experience required access powerful
tools to help you find customers Drive
sales and manage your day-to-day gain
knowledge and confidence with extensive
resources to help you succeed and I've
actually been involved with some of that
way back in the day which was awesome
the build a business competition and
other things plus with 24 7 support
you're never alone and let's face it
being an entrepreneur can be lonely but
you have support you have resources you
don't need to feel alone in this case
more than a store Shopify grows with you
and they never stop innovating providing
more and more tools to make your
business better and your life easier go
to shopify.com Tim to sign up for a one
dollar per month trial period it is a
great deal for a great service so I
encourage you to check it out take your
business to the next level today and
learn more by visiting shopify.com Tim
one more time shopify.com Tim all
lowercase
this episode is brought to you by
element spelled lmnt what on Earth is
element it is a delicious sugar-free
electrolyte drink mix I've stocked up on
boxes and boxes of this was one of the
first things that I bought when I saw
covid coming down the pike and I usually
use one to two per day element is
formulated to help anyone with their
electrolyte needs and perfectly suited
to folks following a keto low carb or
paleo diet or if you drink a ton of
water and you might not have the right
balance that's often when I drink it or
if you're doing any type of endurance
exercise mountain biking Etc another
application if you've ever struggled to
feel good on keto low carb or paleo it's
most likely because even if you're
consciously consuming electrolytes
you're just not getting enough and it
relates to a bunch of stuff like a
hormone called aldosterone blah blah
when insulin is low but suffice to say
this is where element again spelled lmnt
can help my favorite flavor by far is
Citrus salt which is a side note you can
also use to make a kick S no sugar
Margarita but for special occasions
obviously you're probably already
familiar with one of the names behind it
Rob wolf Robb Rob Wolfe who is a former
research biochemist and two-time New
York Times best-selling author of The
Paleo Solution and wired to eat Rob
created element by scratching his own
itch that's how it got started his
Brazilian Jiu Jitsu coaches turned him
on to electrolytes as a performance
enhancer things clicked and Bam company
was born so if you're on a low carb diet
or fasting electrolytes play a key role
in relieving hunger cramps headaches
tiredness and dizziness sugar artificial
ingredients coloring all that's garbage
unneeded there's none of that in element
and a lot of names you might recognize
are already using element it was
recommend to be by one of my favorite
athlete friends three Navy SEAL Teams as
prescribed by their Master Chief Marine
units FBI sniper teams at least five NFL
teams who have subscriptions they are
the exclusive hydration partner to Team
USA weightlifting and on and on you can
try it risk-free if you don't like it
element will give you your money back no
questions asked they have extremely low
return rates for a limited time you can
get a free element sample pack with any
purchase it's the perfect way to try all
of their flavors or if you're feeling
generous sharing with a friend who might
enjoy this special offer is available
here at this link drink
lmnt.com Tim that's drink element Again
drink
lmnt.com Tim
[Applause]